why are you allowed to say that she's
not because you allowed to Humble a man
right if a man bro I never said I was
alive
I don't believe I don't believe any of
us have a right to Humble anybody at the
end of the day because we are all we are
all just human and we are all living
life
I just think it's like real like I'd
rather but your reality is different
from mine but it's you guys keep
forgetting perception is everything in
this world like there's a reason why I
study psychology everything is
perception you guys feel like reality is
no this person is unattractive and this
person is attractive and this is the
beauty standard that we set but there's
hella countries and people out there
that do not exist